[Music]
i asked this question on on twitter
because we're about to talk about tim
pool here real quick
so i asked this uh this question on
twitter
what's a good name for tim pool's band
and these are the top four at least in
my opinion that i found so
the top four are new found glory hole
i like that my chemical bromance
so good fall out of the closet boy
and
pool dole of mud
i i kind of that the first one i think
newfound glory hole
newfound there's no better than newfound
glory oh come on okay thank you that
one's that one's gorgeous that one was
mine thank you okay
what is it
pulling the gang
pulling the ganks not bad but the
problem with that is but the problem is
every time pulls with a gang he fires
the gang
yeah um
okay so let's see what this is
apparently this isn't talking about
rogan having
republican thing on and then he uses it
to plug his music it is ladies and
gentlemen the official
instruction from joe rogan his advice to
people his advice to you
vote republican
it's not so simple and it never is but
in this tweet from kate talks truth with
three thousand nine hundred oh he's so
annoying they're in six retweets it's a
one minute clip where joe rogan
basically tells everybody to vote
talking like this
is he like talking like he sings now yes
but there's something again
he has got some advice for you
what is he doing
sorry it's just
oh what a dick oh what a dick oh what a
dick he titled this video joe rogan says
vote republican over lockdowns and aaron
rodgers exposes fouchy
bro do you know what this i'm skipping
around look you know that that was that
was the um
that was to get people to watch
pharmaceutical industry spent 4.5
billion us dollars on advertising on
national tv in the us unsurprisingly
representing a the new song
all right
let's mix the story with a
self-aggrandizing promo i mean that
somewhat facetiously
my friends in the description below you
will see a link for the new song that we
just put out only ever wanted
what but this but this isn't about joe
rogan says vote republican over
lockdowns aaron rodgers exposes fouchy
stooge pressuring nfl oh my god you're
oh my god yeah he [ __ ] that's not
what this is
that's not what this is he tim rolled us
okay maybe he only covers it for a
little bit
you can buy the song on apple if you
would like to help us smash the charts
we've been sitting at number two on
itunes all songs for the entire platform
all music we are number two
help us beat
britney spears and elton john i don't
know if we can come on man i'm such a
big fan of elton john seriously some of
the best music ever re-released tiny
dancer with britney spears is a dance
pop song okay maybe we'll never get
anywhere close to beating it
can somebody explain why people like tim
pool
i mean and i'm not being a dick because
i mean i know that it's easy to make fun
of him but like
who does he appeal to the the average
midwit like who who's he for he's not
funny so he's not he's not like a comedy
guy so it's not like yeah it's important
he's not he's not principled so he
doesn't have like fans that are
believing that believe in anything right
so he was a bernie bro so like who's
simple for
i i just don't get it
i don't know
i think he is for
like fence sitting sort of like a mild
contrarians
like that's the whole thing like oh tim
pool's cool cause sometimes you know
sometimes he's a you know right wing
sometimes he's not man he's just you
know he moderate left moderate right
yeah he's a [ __ ] he's the centrist's
[ __ ] wet dream
but here's here's what i want to get
into
as i'm reading this news about joe rogan
and i'm thinking about the fact that the
main so so let me say this
we've been basically blacklisted no one
is writing about the two on itunes what
are you talking about blacklisted that
we released a top charting song and i'm
laughing because
we are talking about it you're not i'm
talking we talked about it twice already
three times all i want to do is talk
about it
it sucks he's mad because
he gamed the system yeah he made sure
every single one of his [ __ ] radical
crazy fans bought the album just to push
it up there
they know what he's doing so they're not
acknowledging him
look
if you don't buy my album antifa is
going to win
that's just how it is
do you want any foot a win
boomers that i used to hate but now they
give me money
myself saying of course not i was
hanging out at the casino and there was
a guy mad he's a fan and he was like oh
my god it's just cadence i don't know
man you know i love your show my friend
watches show all the time and i asked
him if he heard about the song he said
no and then he laughed and said but i'm
willing to bet the media won't write
about it right
so you plugged your own song to a random
fan that walked up to you
tim you no did you just did you hear
that yeah yeah that story was really
cringe bro
but that's hey tim i really like your
news coverage and [ __ ] yeah but have you
heard my music bro yeah i'm more into my
music now
and then the guy gave him an out like
yeah but i'm sure they won't you i'm
sure they won't give you any press
because you're so dangerous
that's why you trend on twitter like
weekly
met the president and you were on joe
rogan but they're holding you back tim
the merch version of the story is yeah
like i met a fan i was actually out of
the barn i met a fan
and i asked him hey did you know about
my my my cat youtube stream and he was
like no and like well bro you gotta
watch you gotta watch my cat youtube
stream is the best no and i threw a
drink in his face yes exactly so angry
and then you went to another diner
because they sat somebody in front of
you it'd be more likely i was recognized
from the cat stream yeah probably well
they can't no they can't see you because
it's green screens the green screen yeah
no but before the gay you're the guy
that feeds those cats
yeah
i've seen you and then i laughed and
said you're absolutely correct we have
our communications people reaching out
and they're like not interested not
interested not interested and i'm like
why is nobody's interested because the
song is [ __ ] tim
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] tim
that's honestly what it is
if this song he thought that it was so
good
that he was gonna push his way into the
algorithm and find new audiences that
were going to go oh my god this dude is
everything i've ever wanted from music
and he's like vergie's got a good point
it's just [ __ ] tim if it wasn't for your
audience
if this was a normal upcoming
singer who did this song do you think
it'd be number three or you think nobody
will know who it is because see that's
the thing it's not because it's shooting
up through the it's not shooting up the
like like [ __ ] uh it's not shooting
up through the uh through the charts
because wow we didn't know how good he
was it's because everyone's gonna go
spend 99 cents to support you and i get
it i mean good for you i'm not even
[ __ ] on him for this if you can make
the money make the money like i'm a big
believer in that but don't say that your
song is changing the world and it's a
freedom movement and and and try to
connect it to modern politics all right
you're trying to cash in on your
audience and that's fine but don't
pretend it's bigger than it is you know
yeah he's pretending like oh man they
don't want me because you know they only
want to have their artists at the you
know and write up stuff about their
artists but it's like yeah where do you
think [ __ ] dozier cat came from that
[ __ ] was just making her own little
weird beats and rapping and singing on
their own little things and then she she
did the same thing like she started
putting [ __ ] on the internet
and it started climbing
but the difference between you and her
tim is that other people heard dozier
cat songs and they were like huh
this chick's got something you know what
i mean like she makes some songs where
you're like that's pretty catchy yeah
hey by the way congratulations sam
you're beating the essentials kenny
loggins
[Laughter]
yeah just look at the list i'm looking
at it [ __ ] on itunes nobody buys
music on itunes anymore tim nobody cares
nobody buys music
it's itunes is one of those things
people like you manipulate the charts on
because how is it if you get like
nobody's like virgi's right nobody's
gonna buy
music on itunes anymore unless you're a
self-released artist that has an
audience from something else and you're
like yo go buy this on itunes so i could
be on the itunes charts
the only people that care about itunes
charts are itunes people like itunes
artists
is it that hold me closer number one god
did dj khaled number number three khalid
did you call did he call it dj khaled
yeah he's not a hip-hop guy he's more
like you know they get gay guy yeah
write-ups only ever wanted number two no
write-up
i'll tell you why and it's completely
related to what aaron rodgers and joe
rogan were talking about wow he's
connecting them
yeah it's all connected man
he this is a long-winded promo
that he's he's trying to add just enough
joe rogan to the recipe for it's it's to
be like it's not clickbait
dude he's treating his song like it's a
food bucket
this is the longest live read i've ever
seen
a 20-minute live read typical industry
makes up all these every time yeah
since this uh i know this brings me so
much joy um
tim tim cast is down one slot to number
three now
and the kate bush song that's been
[ __ ] out forever is now back to
number two
so that means tim
you you you this is the equivalent of
you he took that you know that game
where they have the mallet
and they test your strength yeah yeah
yeah and it goes up right so tim that
means that you swung with all your might
bing and you got it all the way up and
it got up to just it didn't hit the bell
it just went all kind of up to the top
and now there's no more momentum right
right you already milked everybody in
his audience you got the you got the
ball up to manly but not hunky you're
number 23 in next week and then it's
down from there buddy
tizen
some of the most the biggest money
though
and it just so happens that people i
never [ __ ] on him for that by the way
i've never shouldn't make your money i'm
not i'm a big believer in that right
yeah he made his money off this
he they they're saying that he was fired
for being anti-vaxx
the daily wire writes it up tim paul
released his first single with ousted
offspring drummer drummer pete perrotta
my major shout out to the daily wire
this is the game my friends
we have his
it was basically breaking benjamin but
it never [ __ ] got to the heavy part
yeah it was a [ __ ] love song
our way into their their their insider's
club
we are not supposed you worked for
disney
[Laughter]
didn't he work for like buzzfeed or
somebody too vice versa
vice that's what it was thank you
insiders club
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now tim
tim your clips come up automatically on
youtube
you're in the club you got to you got to
have a little [ __ ] sidebar with joe
rogan and jack dorsey and the indian
[ __ ] it does all the legal [ __ ]
supposed to be able to do that
they're supposed to control the machine
john rich's song progress
didn't hit the top it hit the top of the
charts didn't get featured
got some write-ups though you can't deny
it by the way tom mcdonald we we
predicted it tom mcdonald did tweet tim
poole
asking about doing a collab
that's not a joke that's not a joke
dude christian we don't it turns out we
didn't need chris chan to do the
dimensional merge
we'll do it ourselves we will carry on
your [ __ ] legacy
except the mom [ __ ] part i am gonna
[ __ ] myself and die the day that tom
[ __ ] mcdonald and temple put their
song out together oh my god it's going
to be too much
it's a coming i'm going to be waking up
that day and i'm going to be like go for
my jog while listening to walking on
sunshine
just waiting for it to come out